>> Laura: A BIG PART OF THE
CHRISTMAS SPIRIT TO TO SEE THE
WORLD WITH INNOCENT EYES OF
WONDER.
THE LESSON KIDS BEST SELLER BY
I LOVE THIS BOOK.
WE WELCOME HER NOW FROM NEW
YORK.
NOW, AINSLEY, WE'RE SO PROUD OF
YOU AND AS WE ALL KNOW, THIS IS
THE TIME OF YEAR TO TAKE STOCK
OF WHO HAS BEEN NAUGHTY AND WHO
HAS BEEN NICE.
SO WE UNDERSTAND YOU'VE BROUGHT
YOUR LIST.
>> I BROUGHT MY CHRISTMAS LIST.
I WOULD SAY ON THE NAUGHTY LIST
AND YOU WOULD AGREE WITH ME
WOULD BE THE MEDIA.
MANY PEOPLE COMPLAIN THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA DOESN'T REPORT
SO I JUST THINK MANY OF THESE
FOLKS THAT CLAIM TO BE
JOURNALISTS WAKE UP EVERY
MORNING AND THEY THINK I HAVE
AN AGENDA TO BASH THE PRESIDENT
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND I
REFUSE TO PUT OUT ANY POSITIVE
STORIES ABOUT HIM.
GRANTED THERE ARE SOME STORIES
THAT MIGHT WARRANT THEIR
COVERAGE BUT THERE ARE MANY
THAT DON'T MAKE IT ON THEIR AIR.
>> Laura: 90% OF THE STORIES
ARE NEGATIVE, I GUESS, YOU'RE
NICER THAN I AM SAYING THEY'RE
JUST NAUGHTY.
>> NASTY.
>> Laura: WE COME UP WITH OUR
NEW LIST.
WHAT ABOUT NICE?
>> THIS IS MY NICE.
I WOULD SAY THE MILITARY.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU THINK ABOUT
ESPECIALLY WITH NORTH KOREA, WE
HAVE MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
MISSING CHRISTMAS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN THIS HOLIDAY SEASON
BECAUSE THEY'RE FIGHTING TO
DEFEND OUR FREEDOM SO THAT WE
CAN LIVE OUR LIVES AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT A TERRORIST
BLOWING UP A CAFE WHERE THAT'S
NOT THE CASE IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
SO I'M VERY PROUD TO BE AN
AMERICAN AND SO GRATEFUL FOR
OUR MILITARY MEN AND WOMEN THAT
DON'T GET THE CREDIT THEY NEED
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL.
THAT REMINDS ME BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED MY BOOK I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT.
DAN ROONEY, I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF GETTING TO NOME HIM OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND HIS FAMILY.
HE SERVED OUR COUNTRY AND HE
WAS COMING BACK FROM A TOUR IN
IRAQ AND THE PILOT CAME OVER
CASKET OFF THIS PLANE.
HE LOOKED OUT THE WINDOW, A
FLAG-DRAPED CASKET.
WHO WILL TEACH THAT LITTLE BOY
TO PLAY BAIL AND PUT HIM
THROUGH COLLEGE AND DECIDED HE
WOULD BE THE ONE.
SINCE THEN HIS ORGANIZATION HAS
RAISED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
PUT KIDS THROUGH COLLEGE AND
LAURA, HE CAME ON OUR SHOW AND
SURPRISED ME AND SAID BECAUSE
YOU ARE FROM SOUTH CAROLINA AND
BECAUSE YOU'VE GIVEN MONEY TO
FOLDS OF HONOR I PRESENTED HIM
WITH A CHECK BECAUSE OF OUR
AMAZING VIEWERS WHO BOUGHT THE
BOOK.
HE SAID BECAUSE YOU GAVE US
$50,000, 10 KIDS WILL GO TO
COLLEGE.
HE WENT DOWN THE LIST.
HE SAID I PICKED OUT KIDS ON
THE LIST.
WE HAVE A LONG LIST OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT THIS COLLEGE MONEY
COUNTRY AND HE WENT DOWN THE
LIST AND FOUND PEOPLE FROM
GOD BLESS HIM.